president biden's approval ratings
plummeting to new lows this week now
nearly six in 10 americans say that they
disapprove of how biden is handling his
job as president the president's
approval rating of falling below 40
percent this past week for the first
time then coming back to 40.6 as
americans push back on progressive
policies this week virginia moving to
end mass mandates in public schools as
several other states have eliminated
mass requirements in the last two weeks
joining me right now to talk more about
all of that after an historic win in
virginia lieutenant governor winsome
sears lieutenant governor it's great to
see you this morning thanks so much for
being with us
thank you for having me maria and good
morning to your listeners
and congratulations to you on your first
vote i want to hear about that why you
did it and what that felt like
lieutenant governor
yeah so my very first tie-breaking vote
which you know i've been trying to get
to for so long
was
a bill that wanted the judges to state
why they gave the sentencing that they
did when they moved out of the
guidelines
and and it's it's a good bill to want to
have except that it was poorly written
it would have had unintended
consequences that we actually could have
foreseen before it happened so you know
i voted against it and some people might
say you voted against the the
incarcerated and no no no i voted
against a poorly written bill would it
which would have made bad law and we
would have had to come back again next
year to fix it so you know you got to
get it right
well this is all part of your push to
ensure the law is followed and
lieutenant governor i think our viewers
this morning are frustrated with the
lawlessness that we see across the
country whether it be unconstitutional
mandates or smash and grabs throughout
california and elsewhere
where is this lawlessness coming from
and what needs to be done
well i think it's coming from the
highest levels and i'm talking about
from the presidency on down where there
is no leadership it's there's a vacuum
and in fact they seem to be following
what's happening on the streets that's
not going to work for anyone because the
leader has to lead that's why they're
called leaders and they have to show the
right way the righteous way there is
right and wrong and you can't look at
what's happening in the streets of smash
and grab and say well it's just social
justice no
it's theft and it's destroying our
economy we've got to have people who are
stopping you know
where's the wind blowing and that's what
we're about they follow the polls and
they don't have a righteous bone in
their body come on let's lead
and you are leading lieutenant governor
i want to take a break and ask you the
importance of education in your life as
well as what's happening in our students
schools these days plus president
biden's pledge to appoint only a black
woman to the supreme court is america
really racist like he keeps suggesting a
lot for you when we come right back stay
with us
that would be unconstitutional because
the constitution article 6 specifically
provides that no religious tests shall
ever be required i think the 14th and
19th amendments also extend that to no
racial or gender tests nobody should
ever be excluded because they don't fit
a racial or gender criteria
that was legal scholar alan dershowitz
with me earlier this month calling
biden's criteria for a supreme court
justice unconstitutional biden has vowed
to nominate a black woman as justice
stephen breyer's replacement and he will
begin meeting with his short list of
candidates this upcoming week i am back
with virginia lieutenant governor
winsome sears and lieutenant governor
i'm going to get to the scotus
appointment in a moment but first i've
got to get your take on what's going on
across the country in terms of the masks
coming off i know that governor younkin
using emergency powers to expedite a
bill to end the school mass mandates but
lieutenant governor the teachers union
boss randy weingarten is saying that the
real issue when it comes to coveted
restrictions is making people feel safe
not the actual science she says she
believes kids and teachers should wear
masks until there's zero transmission is
this about power and control tell us how
you see it from virginia's standpoint
yeah well she doesn't speak for us she
doesn't speak for the parents the
parents voted for our ticket the parents
voted for governor younkin myself and
jason miyares and by the way they voted
for our house so that we could have some
semblance of reasonableness coming back
you know common sense folks has walked
back into our government here in
virginia and virginia is leading the way
so the governor fulfilled his campaign
promise and he told
everybody if you want to wear a mask
wear a mask but allow the parents to
make that decision for their own
children because as far as we can tell
maria the parents still the children
still belong to their parents they don't
belong to the state not just yet not if
we can help it and so
you know
some parents file
issues with it and now we have a bill
that's going through and it looks like
it will fully pass and we'll have the
law here that parents will make that
decision after all
oh my goodness lieutenant governor
parents across the country right now are
rooting you on and thanking you they are
grateful for your leadership i can tell
you for sure look at all of these
policies and what they've produced on
friday oil prices uh passed 94 dollars a
barrel joe biden on his first day in
office killed the xl pipeline uh and we
have higher gasoline prices as a result
and oil prices at 94 dollars a barrel is
there anything you can do in the
leadership uh in virginia to counter
this inflation that americans are
feeling
well one of the things that we are going
to be doing and we have started doing is
to get rid of the the gas tax we're
trying uh i think it passed the house i
think it failed in the senate so now the
house bills are coming over to the
senate and i think that people are
beginning the centers are beginning to
understand this is real this is really
hurting our pocketbooks and you may have
enough money to carry you through but
the rank and file do not and by the way
i'm part of the rank and file i don't
have a lot of money either so i
understand the pain and then we also
have the food tax we need to get rid of
that i mean even the outgoing democrat
governor understood that that had
that was necessary so governor young can
propose all of these to to help the
people and by the way the business tax
to say small businesses have suffered
greatly from what the outgoing
administration governor northam had made
decisions about winners and losers
closed mom-and-pop stores kept the big
box doors open and you see what has
happened it's destroyed part of us so
you know we have got to get this thing
together and we hope the senators who
are democrats will work with us to get
it through because everybody is
suffering
you are the first black woman elected
chief executive of a u.s state
congratulations what are your thoughts
on president biden's pledge to appoint
only a black woman to uh the supreme
court
i'm actually second in command
so that that's interesting because you
know here i am second in command of the
former capital of the confederacy no one
can say then that we haven't gotten a
long way from where we started and
furthermore i'm an immigrant you know i
wasn't even born in america and look
america has given me opportunities to
succeed now we haven't said you know i'm
not going to say that we haven't had
problems of course we've had you know
slavery was an issue and we've had
redlining segregation
blue code laws miscegenation laws but
here i sit to say we are not back in
those days
are there are there problems still yes
but here i am and we are overcoming
america is becoming more and more we
have a saying in church you know i may
not be what i'm supposed to be but i
ain't what i used to be and that's
america so we're coming back to the
judgeships you know it really isn't
unheard of for america to to pick
certain people to to be on the the
supreme court you know we did it when we
wanted we clamored for a female judge
and we got sanjay o'connor that was a
good thing we clam it for a black judge
and we got thurgood marshall that was a
good thing and here we have a latina
judge and uh we have sonia sotomayor you
know it might not be the politics that
we like but we have her and and uh so
and and then
for the first hundred years of the
supreme court's history
those people expected the court to be
partisan and in fact they were highly
partisan so what i'm hoping is that the
president will bring us a judge you know
if she's black will bring us a judge who
respects the constitution and will
uphold the laws and will not be a
partisan
you know who will judge fairly most
importantly that's what we need
that's what we all need and what we all
want lieutenant governor as you're
speaking i'm getting the chills we know
that we will be following your journey
and this will not be your last stop on
the journey
lieutenant governor it's great to have
you this morning please come back soon
thank you so much for your leadership
thank you for having me and please pray
for our troops who are already in poland
and
you know i know there is a time for
peace and a time for war but let's hope
that we don't have to go to war
well said thank you so much lieutenant
governor
winsome sears